That's why you called that man so much and ran away
But there's no octopus,
right?  I don't know
anything about it, but I wonder if it
will work out or if I fail
You've always called me your best friend, but
today is the first time I've ever thought I'd face you face-to-face  I want you to
listen to what I'm saying from now on I
think I can probably say it only once I'm sorry
You and Jun'ichirō are in the situation they're in now It's all my
fault  I'm glad
you're the way
you are No one wants you to change I'm not
crying
Poor Misuzu I think I was
cornering you
Blood was just cornering itself on its own
More importantly, go ahead and
get the template,
just like you
I'm glad you're my best friend